بالنسبة للكثيرين ، إنها أشياء من الكوابيس ،
لكن كن منفتحًا ، فقد يكون هذا
عشاء الليلة ، ثم ستضم هذه الفرقة
حوالي ستة أزهار وصراصير.
إنهم
يتوسعون ليصبحوا أول شركة في
بريطانيا تنتج حشرات للاستهلاك البشري
على نطاق صناعي ، فأنت تحصل على
كيلوغرام زائد على الأقل من البروتين من تلك
الشريحة التي تحتوي على 25 جرامًا من
البروتين أي أكثر من 40 شريحة لحم في
كل من هذه الشرائح.  صناديق لذا يأمل جو
أن ينظر الناس إلى القيمة الغذائية
بدلاً من النظر بعيدًا
ولكن هناك انبعاثات إيجابية أخرى من
الحكمة أنها صديقة للبيئة
لأنها تشغل مساحة صغيرة جدًا
وينمون بسرعة حقًا وهم مستعدون
لها  الحصاد لأسابيع بعد
الفقس ، ثم يتم تجميده وغسله جيدًا
وضعه في تسخين الميكروويف حتى درجة حرارة الغليان ،
مما يؤدي إلى قتل أي بكتيريا
ومن الجيد أن تذهب ولكن لا يزال من الصعب القول
أنها لاذعة  لن يبدو هذا أبدًا
فاتح للشهية ، أود أن أقول شريحة لحم ،
لكن ما نحتاجه الآن هو بعض
الطهاة الجيدين وعلماء الطعام للوقوف
وراء المنتج وتقديم بعض الأطباق اللذيذة حقًا
وهذا هو بالضبط ما تحاول الشيف مارثا
أورتيز القيام به ، لقد كانت بطيئة
إدخال أطباق الحشرات في قائمة الطعام
في مطعم "السوق المكسيكي" الخاص بها
في لندن مثل طبق guacamole
National Instant المزين بجندب ذهبي
حتى التكسير الذي تعلم
أنه شيء رائع جدًا
وماذا يعتقد عملاؤها أنهم يحبونه
يطلبون المزيد تعرفهم  يريدون المزيد
لتجربته ، يقولون إن
هذا رائع ، إنه لذيذ ولكن جرب
واحدة ستقع في حبهم ، أنا
متأكد من أن هذا مخيف بعض الشيء ، لا في الوقت الحالي ،
قد تكون الحشرات فقط من أجل الموارد الأكثر
جرأة ولكن محدودة و
قد يجعل النمو السكاني تناول
هذه ضرورة عالمية بدلاً من
اختيار يا إلهي لمشاهدة CNN Ely